beaucoup de personnes pensent que la Terre est plate
et infinie en termes de ressources.
Mais une fois que vous comprenez vraiment que c'est une sphère
et qu'elle n'est pas infinie,
alors, vous commencez à gérer vos ressources
et à y penser comme un système fini.
Le Vaisseau Terre était sa métaphore.
Et j'ai voulu que ça soit le cas,
mais sous LSD j'étais de plus en plus perché avec mes 100 microgrammes
sur le toit de San Francisco
et j'ai remarqué que les bâtiments qui étaient juste devant moi
n'étaient pas parallèles du tout, ils étaient un peu déployés comme ça.
Et ça c'est parce qu'ils étaient sur une surface courbe.
Et si j'étais plus haut, je le verrais plus clairement,
et encore plus haut, encore plus clairement,
et si haut que ça serait proche,
du cercle de la Terre vue de l'espace.
Et je pensais, ça faisait 10 ans que nous étions allé dans l'espace,
c'était l'année 66,
et les caméras n'avaient jamais regardé en arrière.
Elles regardaient toujours le ciel ou seulement des morceaux de la Terre.
Je me suis dit : pourquoi n'a-t-on pas une photographie de la Terre entière ?
L'idée a fait son tour, la NASA l'a eue, les sénateurs, les ministres l'ont eue,
et des personnes variées du bureau politique l'ont eue,
et l'idée s'est baladée.
Après deux ans et demi,
quand le Whole Earth Catalog est sorti,
ces images commençaient à apparaître,
et en effet, elles ont tout transformé.
Et mon idée de pirater la civilisation
est que vous essayez de faire quelque chose de paresseux et d'ingénieux
et en un sens, de simplement manipuler la situation.
Alors toutes ces photos que vous voyez...
La marche pour la science la semaine dernière,
ils portaient ces banderoles de la Terre est ronde, etc...
J'ai fait cela sans travail.
J'ai vendu ces revues pour 25 cents chacune.
Alors, vous savez, manipuler le système
est, non seulement, la façon la plus efficace
de le faire avancer dans une direction intéressante,
mais aussi, la manière la plus sûre,
car quand vous essayez de forcer tout le système dans une direction différente,
vous pouvez vous retrouver face à de gros problèmes,
mais si vous le tordez, il s'ajustera.
CA : Donc, depuis lors, entre autres,
vous avez été vu comme leader dans le mouvement écolo,
mais vous êtes aussi de la contre-culture,
et récemment, vous avez beaucoup parlé de...
enfin, vous avez déclaré que
ce que beaucoup d'écologistes croient sont des hérésies.
J'aimerais en détailler quelques exemples.
Parlez-moi de cette image-là.
SB : Ha ! ha !
C'est une image du National Geographic
de ce qu'on appelle la steppe mammouth,
ce à quoi le nord lointain, les régions subarctiques et arctiques ressemblaient.
En fait, le monde entier ressemblait à cela.
Ce qu'on trouve en Afrique du Sud et dans le Serengeti aujourd'hui,
beaucoup de gros animaux
étaient communs dans cette partie du Canada,
à travers les États-Unis, à travers l'Eurasie, à travers le monde.
C'était la norme
et cela pourrait l'être à nouveau.
Alors dans un sens,
mon but à long terme sur ce point n'est pas seulement de ramener ces animaux
et la prairie qu'ils ont créée,
ce qui pourrait être un système de stabilisation climatique à long terme,
mais également les mammouths, là à l'arrière-plan,
qui en font aussi partie.
Et je crois que c'est probablement un objectif à 200 ans.
Peut-être 100.
A la fin de ce siècle, nous devrions être capables de réduire le taux d'extinction
à ce qu'il a été dans le passé.
Ramener ce montant d'abondance prendra plus de temps,
mais cela en vaut la peine.
CA : Nous reviendrons aux mammouths,
mais expliquez-nous comment nous devrions penser aux extinctions.
Manifestement, l'une des grandes préoccupations de notre temps est
que les extinctions se produisent plus rapidement que jamais dans l'histoire.
C'est l'idée dominante actuellement.
Comment devrait-on penser à cela ?
SB : L'idée actuelle est
que nous sommes au milieu de la sixième Extinction
ou peut-être au début de la sixième Extinction.
Car nous sommes dans le mouvement de dés-extinction,
de prévention des extinctions avec Revive & Restore,
nous avons regardé ce qu'il en était vraiment de cette extinction.
Et il s'avère qu'il y a un ensemble de données très confuses ici
qui deviennent trop simplistes
dans l'histoire de ce que nous devenons.
Voilà cinq extinctions de masse qui sont indiquées par les triangles jaunes,
et maintenant nous sommes la prochaine.
La dernière là, au bout à droite
est le météore qui a frappé il y a 66 millions d'années
et qui a éradiqué les dinosaures.
L'idée est que nous sommes le prochain météore.
Bien, voilà la réalité.
J'ai fait des recherches sur le sujet pour un article :
une extinction de masse se produit quand 75% de toutes les espèces
du monde disparaissent.
Il existe à peu près 5,5 millions d'espèces.
Nous en avons déjà identifié 1,5 million.
Et 14 000 nouvelles sont identifiées chaque année.
Il y a beaucoup de biologie impliquée.
Depuis 1500,
à peu près 500 espèces se sont éteintes,
et vous verrez l'expression « extinction de masse » utilisé d'une façon étrange.
Donc on a eu, il y a environ un an et demi,
un article en première page de Carl Zimmer dans le New York Times.
« Extinction de masse dans les océans d'après une vaste étude. »
Et puis vous lisez l'article, et celui-ci mentionne que depuis 1500,
15 espèces se sont éteintes dans les océans,
et, soit dit en passant, aucune dans les 50 dernières années.
Vous allez plus loin dans l'article, ça dit :
la chose horrible qui est en train d'arriver
est que la surpêche des poissons sauvages est telle
que la quantité de poissons dans les océans
a été réduite de 38%.
Ça, c'est ce qui est sérieux.
Il est probable qu'aucune de ces espèces ne s'éteindra.
Alors vous avez ce rédacteur
qui met un bouton d'alarme
dans le titre de son histoire.
C'est un genre de piège à clics.
Mais il dit pratiquement : « Oh mon Dieu, commencez à paniquer,
nous allons perdre toutes les espèces des océans. »
Rien de cela n'est prévu.
Et en fait, quand j'ai ensuite commencé à analyser le sujet un peu plus en détail,
la liste rouge recense environ 23 000 espèces considérées comme menacées
d'une façon ou d'une autre,
d'après l'Union Internationale pour la Conservation de la Nature.
Et on a eu un article dans le magazine Nature examinant la perte de la faune,
et ça disait :
« Si toutes ces 23 000 espèces disparaissaient
dans le prochain siècle ou presque,
et que ce taux d'extinction perdurait sur plusieurs siècles et millénaires,
alors, nous pourrions être au commencement d'une sixième extinction. »
L'exagération est hors de contrôle.
Mais les écologistes exagèrent toujours.
C'est un problème.
CA : Ils ressentent probablement une responsabilité morale.
Ils se soucient tellement des choses qu'ils voient,
et à moins que vous ne sonniez le tocsin, personne n'écoute.
SB : Chaque fois que quelqu'un dit moral ceci ou moral cela,
« risque moral », « principe préventif »,
ce sont des mots qui, en réalité, sont utilisés pour dire « non ».
CA : Alors le problème ne serait pas tant l'extinction des poissons, des animaux,
mais l'abondance des poissons, des animaux,
auxquels on mettrait la pression dans une certaine mesure.
SB : Oui, et je crois qu'il y a de la pression et que des pertes sont en cours.
Les plus grandes pertes sont causées par l'agriculture.
Donc tout ce qui améliore l'agriculture, qui la rend plus concentrée,
plus productive,
incluant les OGMs, s'il vous plaît...
Si vous voulez faire des fermes verticales en ville,
et des fermes d'intérieur,
tout ce qui a été appris sur comment faire pousser de l'herbe dans les caves,
sert maintenant pour faire pousser des légumes dans des conteneurs...
C'est génial, c'est que du bon,
car limiter la surface est la meilleure chose qu'on puisse faire pour la nature.
Les gens qui vont habiter en ville, c'est bien.
Faire que l'agriculture détruise moins de paysages, c'est bien.
CA : Des gens parlent de réintroduction d'espèces, de ré-ensauvagement...
Pour commencer, la réintroduction d'espèces, c'est quoi cette histoire ?
SB : Ha-ha ! Les loups.
L'Europe... Pour rejoindre le point précédent,
on est probablement au maximum des terres cultivées.
Également, en termes de population,
nous sommes déjà à un pic du nombre d'enfants vivants.
Dorénavant, il y aura de moins en moins d'enfants.
Nous sommes sur le dernier doublement de la population humaine,
et on atteindra neuf milliards, peut-être neuf milliards et demi,
Ensuite ça devrait arrêter de croître, et même probablement diminuer.
De même, la quantité de terres cultivées a atteint un sommet,
et une des façons dont cela se déroule en Europe
est qu'il y a maintenant beaucoup de terres cultivées abandonnées,
qui se reboisent immédiatement.
Ils ne font pas de corridors pour la faune en Europe.
Ils n'en ont pas besoin, car ces fermes sont si connectées
qu'elles forment des passages reboisés pour la faune,
grâce auxquels les loups reviennent. Dans ce cas, depuis l'Espagne.
Ils sont allés jusqu'aux Pays-Bas.
Les ours reviennent, les lynx reviennent.
Il y a le chacal européen. Je n'avais aucune idée que ça existait.
Depuis l'Italie, ils essaiment dans le reste de l'Europe.
Et à l'inverse d'ici, ce sont tous des prédateurs, ce qui est intéressant.
Ils sont bien accueillis par les Européens, ils leur manquaient.
CA : Et contre-intuitivement, quand vous réintroduisez les prédateurs,
cela augmente plutôt que réduit la diversité de l'écosystème sous-jacent.
SB : Oui, généralement les prédateurs et les gros animaux ;
les gros animaux et les gros animaux avec des dents pointues et des griffes
s'avèrent être extrêmement importants pour un écosystème réellement riche.
CA : Ce qui nous amène à ce projet plus impressionnant de ré-ensauvagement
dans lequel vous vous êtes impliqué.
Pourquoi voudrait-on réintroduire ces terrifiants mammouths laineux ?
SB : Hmm. Les éléphants d'Asie sont les cousins les plus proches
des mammouths laineux,
ils ont presque la même taille, sont très proches génétiquement.
Ils ont divergé assez récemment dans l'histoire de l'Évolution.
Les éléphants d'Asie sont plus proches des mammouths
qu'ils ne le sont des éléphants d'Afrique
mais ils sont assez proches des éléphants d'Afrique
pour s'accoupler avec succès.
Alors nous travaillons avec George Church à Harvard,
qui a déjà inséré les gènes de quatre traits majeurs
du génome très préservé et très étudié du mammouth laineux,
grâce à ce que l'on appelle l'analyse d'ADN ancestral.
Et en labo, il a inséré ces gènes dans des cellules vivantes d'un éléphant d'Asie
où ils s'insèrent à l'emplacement correct grâce à CRISPR.
Je veux dire, ils n'introduisent pas ces gènes au hasard comme on le faisait avant.
Maintenant avec CRISPR vous éditez, réellement, un allèle,
pour le remplacer par un autre allèle.
Alors vous récupérez maintenant des cellules germinales d'éléphant d'Asie
qui sont effectivement, au niveau des caractéristiques que vous recherchez,
adaptés à l'Arctique.
Vous allez les mettre là.
Alors on suit ce procédé
d'obtenir cela grâce à une mère porteuse,
une mère éléphante d'Asie.
Vous pouvez obtenir un proxy, comme les biologistes de conservation le dénomment,
du mammouth laineux,
qui est en fait un éléphant d'Asie poilu aux défenses courbes
parfaitement adapté au climat subarctique.
Maintenant que c'est parti, beaucoup disent :
« Comment allez-vous les mettre là-bas ?
Les éléphants d'Asie n'aiment pas la neige. »
En fait, ils aiment la neige.
Il y en a dans un zoo en Ontario
qui ont fait des boules de neige plus grandes que nous.
Ils adorent. Avec une trompe, ils en font une petite,
la font rouler, grossir.
Les gens disent aussi :
« Oui, mais c'est 22 mois de gestation.
Ce type de clonage entre les espèces est une affaire délicate, de toute façon.
Allez-vous perdre certaines des éléphantes mères porteuses ? »
Et George Church dit :
« Okay, on va fabriquer un utérus artificiel. »
Puis les gens disent : « Ouais, le siècle prochain, peut-être, »
sauf que qu'on a appris la nouvelle cette semaine dans Nature
qu'il y a maintenant un utérus artificiel dans lequel un agneau a grandi
jusqu'à quatre semaines.
C'est la moitié de sa période de gestation.
Alors ces choses avancent.
CA : Mais pourquoi devrons-nous vouloir un monde où...
Imaginez un monde où il y a des milliers de ces choses
rugissant à travers la Sibérie.
Est-ce un monde meilleur ?
SB : Potentiellement. C'en est un...
Il y a trois groupes qui travaillent sérieusement sur le mammouth :
on a Revive & Restore, on est un peu au milieu ;
Il y a George Church et le groupe à Harvard qui font la génétique en labo.
Et puis il y a un vieux scientifique incroyable qui s'appelle Zimov
qui travaille en Sibérie du Nord,
et son fils Nikita, qui s'est investi dans l'histoire.
Sergey et Nikita Zimov créent, depuis 25 ans,
ce qu'ils appellent le Parc Pléistocène,
qui est un endroit très rude de la Sibérie, de la pure toundra.
Et la recherche qui y est faite montre
qu'il y a probablement aujourd'hui seulement un centième des animaux
qu'il y a eu jadis sur ce territoire.
Comme cette image avant, où on a vu plein d'animaux.
Désormais, il n'y en a presque plus.
La toundra est surtout de la mousse, il y a la forêt boréale.
Et c'est comme ça. Il y a que quelques animaux là.
Alors ils ont introduit beaucoup de ruminants :
bœuf musqué, chevaux de Yakoutie, et puis quelques bisons.
Ils en rapportent plus maintenant,
et les mettent en densité égale à ce qu'elle était jadis.
Et les prairies sont faites par les ruminants.
Alors ces animaux sont là, broutant,
et ils font quelques trucs.
Premièrement, ils transforment la toundra, la mousse, en prairie.
Les prairies fixent le carbone.
La toundra, dans un monde qui se réchauffe, dégèle
et relâche beaucoup de dioxyde de carbone et de méthane.
Rien que dans leurs petits 65 000 km²,
ils font quelque chose pour stabiliser le climat.
Cependant, une partie du tableau
est que la forêt boréale absorbe une grande partie de la lumière du soleil,
même pendant l'hiver quand la neige recouvre la terre.
Et la steppe mammouth,
qui enveloppait tout le tour du pôle Nord -
il y a beaucoup de terre autour du pôle Nord -
tout ça était de la prairie.
Et la steppe mammouth était magnifique,
probablement un des biomes les plus productifs au monde,
le plus grand biome du monde.
La forêt en est une partie, maintenant, Sergey Zimov et Nikita
sortent ce vieux tank militaire qu'ils ont récupéré pour rien,
et ils abattent les arbres.
Et ça c'est ennuyant, et c'est fatigant,
et comme Sergey le dit : « Ils ne font pas de fumier ! »
Ce que, en passant, ces grands animaux font, notamment les mammouths.
Alors les mammouths deviennent ce que les biologistes de conservation appellent
une espèce parapluie.
C'est un animal enthousiasmant - les pandas en Chine par exemple.
L'excitation qui va avec la création de bonnes conditions de vie pour cet animal,
c'est de créer un habitat, un écosystème,
qui est bon pour tout un tas de créatures et de plantes,
et on arrive idéalement au point d'être autonome,
où les biologistes de conservation peuvent se retirer et dire :
« Tout ce qu'on doit faire est d'empêcher les envahissants destructeurs d'entrer,
et la sauce va prendre. »
CA : Il y a de nombreuses autres espèces que vous rêvez de restaurer
à un moment,
mais je crois que ce que j'aimerais vraiment évoquer
est l'idée dont vous avez parlé : comment les mammouths pourraient
aider à reverdir la Sibérie dans un sens,
ou du moins - je ne parle pas de forêt tropicale -
mais cette idée de reverdir la planète sur laquelle vous avez beaucoup réfléchi.
Et l'idée commune est
que la déforestation est l'une des tragédies les plus affreuses
des temps modernes,
et que c'est une contribution énorme au changement climatique.
Et puis vous m'avez envoyé ce graphique ici, ou cette carte.
Qu'est-ce que cette carte ?
SB : Le reverdissement mondial.
La chose à faire avec n'importe quelle histoire,
que vous lisez dans les gros titres, dans les courtes nouvelles,
est de regarder ce qui se passe d'autre, en parallèle,
et de chercher ce que Marc Andreessen appelle « la violation de l'histoire ».
Alors l'histoire - et Al Gore en est le maître -
est qu'il y a ce changement climatique menaçant la civilisation
qui avance très rapidement.
Nous devons cesser toute la production excédentaire des gaz à effet de serre,
notamment le CO2, dans les plus brefs délais,
sinon, nous allons droit dans le mur.
Tout cela est vrai, mais ce n'est pas toute l'histoire,
et l'histoire complète est plus intéressante que ces petits morceaux.
Les plantes adorent le CO2.
Ce dont les plantes sont faites, c'est du CO2 plus de l'eau et du soleil.
Dans les serres industrielles,
ils ajoutent du CO2 car les plantes le transforment en matière végétale.
Les études ont été faites avec des satellites et autres,
et ce que vous voyez ici est un graphique, des 33 dernières années, plus ou moins.
Il y a 14% d'activité en plus pour les feuilles.
Autant de biomasse en plus.
Autant de ce que les écologistes appellent la production primaire.
Il y a autant de vie en plus,
grâce au changement climatique,
grâce à toutes nos putains de centrales à charbon.
Alors, ouah, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
En passant, la productivité agricole augmente de même.
C'est une compensation partielle
à l'augmentation du CO2,
car il y a cette quantité de plantes en plus qui l'intègrent
en matière végétale.
Une partie pourrit et retourne dans l'air,
mais une partie descend dans les racines
et passe dans le sol, et y reste.
Alors ces réactions sont une partie des choses que vous devez avoir en tête,
et le tableau plus complet est
que penser au climat, s'en occuper et le modifier
est un processus assez complexe.
C'est comme la médecine.
Vous êtes toujours, de nouveau, en train d'ajuster le système
pour voir ce qui fait qu'il s'améliore.
Puis vous continuez, voir s'il s'améliore toujours.
Oups ! C'est assez, faites demi-tour.
CA : Mais certains pourraient dire, « Tout le vert n'a pas été créé égal »
Peut-être qu'on troque la splendeur de la forêt tropicale
et toute sa diversité
contre, je ne sais pas, des algues, du gazon ou quelque chose comme ça.
SB : Dans cette étude, il se trouve que chaque type de plante s'améliore.
Mais, ce qui est curieusement omis de cette étude
est ce qu'il se passe dans les océans.
La production primaire dans les océans,
le biote des océans, principalement microbien,
fait ce qui est probablement la chose la plus importante.
Ce sont eux qui créent l'atmosphère
que nous respirons gaiement,
et ils ne font pas partie de cette étude.
C'est une des choses sur laquelle James Lovelock insistait.
En gros, notre connaissance des océans, particulièrement de la vie océanique,
est réellement vaporeuse, en ce sens.
Alors nous sommes en train de découvrir,
par l'involontaire géo-ingénierie d'envoyer trop de CO2 dans l'atmosphère,
en train de découvrir comment l'océan réagit à ça.
L'océan, avec la chaleur excédentaire,
se dilate.
C'est surtout de là que vient l'élévation du niveau de la mer,
et ça va continuer avec la suite du réchauffement.
On voit des dommages terribles à certains récifs coralliens,
comme au large de l'Australie.
La grande barrière de corail a beaucoup blanchi à cause de la surchauffe.
Et c'est pourquoi Danny Hillis et moi, dans notre précédente séance sur scène,
disions : « Regardez, la géo-ingénierie vaut le coup d'être expérimentée
à cette échelle pour voir que ça fonctionne,
pour voir si on peut gagner du temps avec le réchauffement,
ajuster un peu le système avec de la recherche utile,
et puis ensuite, voir si nous devrions faire plus qu'ajuster.
CA : OK, alors c'est de cela qu'on va discuter
pour nos dernières minutes
car c'est vraiment important.
Tout d'abord, ce livre vient d'être publié par Yuval Harari.
Il dit essentiellement que la prochaine évolution humaine
sera de devenir comme des dieux. Je crois qu'il...
SB : Vous lui avez parlé. Et vous avez probablement fini le livre.
Je ne l'ai pas encore fini.
A quelle conclusion arrive-t-il ?
CA : Bon, c'est une opinion assez radicale.
Il croit que nous nous re-fabriquerons entièrement
utilisant les données, utilisant la bio-ingénierie,
pour devenir des créatures entièrement nouvelles
qui ont des sortes de superpouvoirs,
et qu'il va y avoir de grandes inégalités.
Mais nous sommes sur le point d'écrire un chapitre totalement nouveau
et radical de notre histoire C'est ce qu'il croit.
SB : Est-il inquiet à ce propos ? J'ai oublié.
CA : Il est inquiet à ce propos,
mais je crois aussi qu'il aime provoquer les gens.
SB : Êtes-vous inquiet à ce propos ?
CA : Je suis inquiet à ce propos.
Mais, vous savez, avec autant de choses à TED, je suis enthousiaste et inquiet.
Et l'optimiste en moi essaye férocement d'aller de l'avant -
« C'est génial et vraiment excitant » -
quand mon côté assez responsable dit :
« Mais peut-être que nous devrions être prudents
quand nous pensons à ça. »
SB : C'est votre ingrédient secret pour TED, n'est-ce pas ?
C'est rester inquiet et enthousiaste.
CA : C'est aussi la recette pour être un peu schizophrène.
Mais il ne vous a pas cité.
Ce que je trouvais être une déclaration étonnante
dans le Whole Earth Catalog originel,
vous le terminiez alors avec cette phrase forte :
« Nous sommes comme des dieux, et on pourrait bien devenir bons à ça. »
Récemment, vous avez amélioré cette expression.
J'aimerais discuter de cette philosophie.
SB : Bien, une des choses que j'apprends est que les écrits
sont meilleurs que la mémoire... de loin.
Et une des choses que j'ai apprises de quelqu'un...
Je suis en fait allé sur Twitter.
Ça a changé ma vie. Ça ne m'a toujours pas pardonné !
Et j'ai pris propriété de cette expression quand quelqu'un l'a citée,
et quelqu'un d'autre a dit :
« Oh au fait, ce n'est pas ce que vous avez écrit
dans ce premier Whole Earth Catalog de 1968,
mais : « Nous sommes comme des dieux et on pourrait bien s'y habituer. »
J'avais totalement oublié ça.
Les histoires, ces sacrées histoires, ces histoires qu'on se raconte
deviennent peu à peu des mensonges.
Alors, les écrits nous aident à éviter cela.
Ça s'est transformé en : « Nous sommes comme des dieux
et on pourrait bien devenir bons à ça, » c'était le Whole Earth Catalog.
A cette époque, j'écrivais un livre « Whole Earth Discipline :
Un Manifeste Éco-Pragmatique »,
et à la lumière du changement climatique, je disais que
nous étions comme des dieux et qu'on devait devenir bons à ça.
CA : Nous sommes comme des dieux et nous devons être bons à ça.
Parlons de cela, car la réaction psychologique
dès que vous commencez à discuter de géo-ingénierie est
que devenir des dieux est la dernière chose à faire.
Pour des raisons religieuses,
mais pour la plupart uniquement pour des raisons d'humilité,
que les systèmes sont trop complexes,
nous ne devrions pas aller dans cette direction.
SB : Bien, c'est le récit grec sur l'orgueil démesuré.
Et quand vous commencez à devenir vraiment sûr de vous,
vous finissez par coucher avec votre mère.
(Rires)
CA : Je ne m'attendais pas à ce que vous disiez cela.
SB : C'est l'histoire d'Œdipe.
L'orgueil démesuré, un conte de prudence très important à garder sous le coude.
Une des lignes de conduite que j'applique est :
chaque jour, je me demande sur combien de choses j'ai tout faux.
Et je suis un scientifique de formation
et j'ai la chance de travailler avec des scientifiques,
ce n'est que du bonheur.
La science est du scepticisme organisé.
Alors vous insistez toujours
que même quand quelque chose a l'air assez bon,
vous maintenez un ensemble complet, non seulement de méfiances
à propos du fait que ça soit aussi bon,
mais aussi : Que se passe-t-il d'autre ?
Alors cette question de « Qu'est ce qu'il se passe d'autre ? »
je crois que c'est ainsi que vous vous gardez des fausses nouvelles.
Ce ne sont pas nécessairement de vraies informations,
mais ce sont certainement des informations plus complexes
que vous essayez d'intégrer.
CA : Mais revenons à son application sur l'environnement.
Il semble que cette philosophie est que, qu'on le veuille ou non,
on impacte déjà tellement ce qu'il se passe sur les planètes,
et on le fait involontairement,
que nous devrions vraiment commencer à faire ces choses intentionnellement.
A quoi ça ressemblerait si on commençait à devenir bons en tant que dieux ?
Comment devrions-nous commencer ?
Y a-t-il des expériences à petite échelle, ou des systèmes
qu'on peut ajuster et analyser ? Comment réfléchir à ça ?
SB : Le mentor qui m'a libéré d'un sens
de l'allégeance totale à Buckminster Fuller
a été Gregory Bateson.
Gregory Bateson était un épistémologue, un anthropologue, un biologiste,
un psychologue et bien d'autres choses,
et il regardait comment les systèmes, fondamentalement, s'auto-analysaient.
C'est en partie comme ça, je crois, que vous devriez toujours examiner les choses.
Et ce que j'aime sur l'approche de la géo-ingénierie de David Keith
est que ne vous contentez pas de vous lancer d'un coup.
L'approche de David Keith,
et c'est de ça que Danny Hillis discutait auparavant,
est que vous le faites vraiment, vraiment, progressivement,
vous faites quelque chose pour modifier le système, voyez comment il répond,
cela vous enseigne quelque chose sur le système.
Cela répond au fait que les gens demandent, avec raison :
« De quoi parle-t-on au juste ?
On ne comprend pas comment le système climatique fonctionne.
Vous ne pouvez pas modifier un système que vous ne comprenez pas. »
David dit : « Bien, cela s'applique certainement au corps humain,
et pourtant la médecine avance, et nous en sommes plutôt heureux. »
La façon de modifier un système qui est si large et si complexe
qu'on ne peut pas le comprendre entièrement
est de l'altérer,
et cette approche est assez anti-présomptueuse.
C'est : Essayez un peu ceci,
reculez franchement s'il y a un problème,
continuez si ça semble marcher,
pendant ce temps, laissez le reste se poursuivre.
C'est tout l'argument de la diversité, du dialogue, de toutes ces autres choses
et des choses qu'on a entendues auparavant avec Sebastian [Thrun].
Alors l'approche non-présomptueuse est de rechercher l'acceptation sociale
qui est une terminologie que je crois être bonne.
D'inclure suffisamment la société
dans ces problématiques profondes, intéressantes
dont ils peuvent avoir une assez bonne idée
et d'avoir des personnes en qui ils ont confiance qui observent minutieusement
la série d'expériences en route.
Le dialogue public qui évolue,
qui est plus public que jamais, ce qui est fantastique,
et vous vous laissez guider,
vous vous contentez de faire votre chemin.
C'est l'approche débrouillarde qui a marché assez bien jusqu'à présent.
La raison pour laquelle Sebastian et moi sommes optimistes est que nous lisons
des gens comme Steven Pinker, « Les Meilleurs Anges de Notre Nature »,
et jusqu'ici tout va bien.
Bon, cela peut toujours changer,
mais vous pouvez construire beaucoup sur cette idée :
les choses peuvent s'améliorer,
trouvez les outils qui améliorent et utilisez-les d'avantage.
C'est ça, le truc.
CA : Stewart, sur cette remarque optimiste,
on va conclure.
Je suis ébahi par la façon dont vous êtes toujours prêt à vous défier vous-même
et à défier les autres.
Je crois que cette idée de ne jamais vous autoriser à être trop sûr
est très puissante.
J'aimerais l'appliquer plus moi-même,
et c'était très pertinent et inspirant, vraiment,
de vous écouter aujourd'hui.
Stewart Brand, merci beaucoup.
SB : Merci.
(Applaudissements)